Professor David Blight:
I suppose every war,
the short ones and the long
ones,
the ones that get televised and
the ones that don't,
the ones where we get to see
the coffins and the ones where
we don't,
have their romance and their
reality.
It seems to be an endless--in
the face of whatever,
modernization of war,
media coverage of war,
the devastating critique of war
as an individual human
experience by so many great
poets and writers for a century
and a half--it doesn't seem to
matter what changes or what
happens,
but youth grow up to be excited
about war.
Ambrose Bierce once wrote that
only--I quote him--"Only fools
forget the causes of war."
But then it's the same Ambrose
Bierce, one of the
most--certainly I think,
the unique American writer
about the Civil War in so many
ways--a kind of bitter,
brutal realist who was wounded
three times in the war,
hit in the head with a shell
shot from a cannon,
should've died--crushed in part
of his skull,
which may explain Ambrose
Bierce actually--but it's Bierce
who also wrote that lovely
little line where he said,
"the soil of peace is thickly
sewn with the seeds of war."
Get too much peace for awhile
and people get anxious.
Americans, when this war broke
out, embraced it with a fever,
that is, an enthusiasm,
an almost indefinable joy,
that may be a little tough to
understand today or appreciate.
It's only in the wake of war,
or in the face of real war,
of course, that people get
reflective.
At the end of it all,
in Lincoln's Second Inaugural,
is this famous passage;
and by the way,
there may be more book titles
drawn from this one page and a
half speech than any other piece
of prose ever penned by an
American;
you can just start ticking off
the book titles that come out of
phrases.
The latest is Jim McPherson's
latest book of essays called
This Mighty Scourge of
War.
At some point we will run out,
it's only a page and a half
after all.
"On the occasion corresponding
to this four years ago"--this is
Lincoln, March,
1865, remembering March
1861--"all thoughts were
anxiously directed to an
impending civil war.
All dreaded it,
all sought to avert it.
While the Inaugural Address was
being delivered from this place
devoted altogether to saving the
Union without war,"
--yeah--"insurgent agents were
in the city seeking to destroy
it, without war,
seeking to dissolve the Union
and divide effects by
negotiation.
Both parties deprecated war,
but one of them would make war,
rather than let the nation
survive,
and the other would accept war,
rather than let it perish.
And the war came."
Well, now that's Lincoln's
argument, isn't it?
One side would make war,
the other side would accept
war.
We're going to revisit that
moment in just a minute,
Lincoln's so-called April
Policy of April 1861,
his maneuvers against Jefferson
Davis's maneuvers about the
single fort in Charleston Harbor
where the Civil War would
actually begin.
Did Lincoln maneuver the South
into the first shot?
Always been a question
unanswered.
Quickly, let me revisit with
you----this question of
causation.
I left that in a bit of
abeyance.
There was a school of
interpretation of this war that
it had a tiny,
an interesting little revival
of late,
in the hands of great
historians, people I greatly
admire like Edward Ayers--and
you've read two of his essays
for this week,
"Worrying About the Civil
War--and my colleague here,
Skip Stout, in a different way.
There's been a kind of a little
revival of this notion that the
Civil War might have been
preventable, that it might have
been needless.
No one is arguing that as
vigorously as James G.
Randall and Avery Craven and a
host of other American
historians did in the 1920s,
'30s and '40s,
up to World War Two.
World War Two is going to
really reshape that
interpretation and put it on the
run.
But I wanted to just visit it a
moment because it shows us not
only the historical
interpretations,
as will be yours,
are influenced by one's own
times, one's own experiences,
one's own assumptions,
one's own sentiments,
and how the world shapes us;
sometimes it comes out of
conviction.
The needless war school of
interpretation was led by James
Randall and Avery Craven.
In Avery Craven's case he was a
Quaker.
But these were men deeply
influenced by the utter
disillusionment of World War
One.
They came of age and cut their
teeth on history at a time when
the world had collapsed into
what seemed to be in the end an
inexplicable meaningless war.
There's that unforgettable
scene at the very beginning of
The Guns of August by
Barbara Tuchman.
No one reads her anymore.
She was at one point the most
popular historian in America.
She wrote about the Middle
Ages, she wrote about world
wars, she wrote about all kinds
of things.
Anyway, at the very opening of
The Guns of August is a
scene where a German general
meets a French general,
somewhere in the mid- or
late-1920s, and the one general
says to the other,
"Sir, why did it happen?"
And the other general says,
"I don't know,
I really don't know."
In the wake of the Bay of Pigs,
and before the Cuban Missile
Crisis, President John Kennedy
gave a copy of The Guns of
August and ordered every
member of his National Security
Council and his cabinet to read
it.
And he quoted that passage,
and he said "never will we,
never shall we be caught having
to answer that question about
war."
I don't know.
In that kind of disillusionment
an interpretation that finds
sheer politics and fanaticism
and aggressive emotionalism,
an overblown kind of--what did
Randall call it--unctuous fury
as the essential explanation of
why the war came in 1861,
can make a certain sense.
There's a beguiling quality to
that argument,
when we look at the folly of
human history and the folly of
human nature.
That all changed in so many
ways in the wake of the Second
World War, a war that was all
about ideology,
all about racism,
all about the survival of
Enlightenment ideas against
fascism and so on and so on;
and a generation led by such
historians as Arthur Schlesinger
Jr., and many,
many, many others,
came to see the American Civil
War's coming,
when they started writing in
the 1950s and '60s and into the
'70s,
as what they would call an
"irrepressible conflict."
And this array of arguments,
they all get kind of lumped
under this heading,
irrepressible conflict thesis,
began to flow from American
historians.
Don Fehrenbacher may have
captured that interpretation
best in a line when he said,
"The Civil War came and it was
fought to bring"--how did he put
it--"to bring great national
progress at great national
cost."
I've never been entirely
comfortable with that idea,
you know, "well it all had to
happen,
it was bloody horrible and
terrible, and all those people
died, but we all got better for
it."
That never, never,
never sits very well with me,
especially when you study the
memory of the war and the
aftermath.
But what happened in post-World
War Two scholarship--and it's
still there, it's still at the
heart of how we try to explain
this most pivotal event,
one of the most pivotal events
of American history--is a
certain respect for moral
questions,
a certain respect for ideas,
and the notion that politics is
sometimes about something.
Now that's an utterly horribly
streamlined way of saying--you
don't find many historians
anymore who argue from a
needless war perspective,
although what you do find is a
kind of rollercoaster ride
through American scholarship
about the Civil War,
sometimes deeply influenced by
Vietnam and sometimes deeply
influenced, even today--some
have argued about Skip Stout's
book;
if you know Professor Stout.
He has a remarkable new book
out about whether the American
Civil War was a just war.
And I will re-visit that
question at the end,
near the end of this course,
and use a couple of his
arguments.
It's a controversial book,
it's an interesting book.
It's a question we've never
truly asked about this good war.
Was it just?
Does it fit?
Does it fulfill the principles
of just war doctrine?
Can it?
Does it matter?
All right, but back to April,
1861.
Whether it was just,
and just why it became so
bloody and so prolonged,
we're going to take up over and
over.
But it surely did happen,
and it began--I don't know if
that map works terribly well,
it probably doesn't;
it's the best I can do this
morning.
It is a map of Charleston
Harbor, which had the last
remaining federal installation,
fort, around the coast of the
American South still in federal
hands by March and April of
1861.
The seven states of the seceded
South, the Deep South,
had begun to seize coastal
forts, they'd begun to seize
federal arsenals.
They seized post offices and
they seized federal courts.
Now I guarantee you today if
you seized a federal court
office building,
and particularly if you killed
anybody in the act,
or if you took over a U.S.
Post Office--I know nobody
cares about post offices because
you do everything online.
Those people down there on Elm
Street, they're such sweet
people;
the idea of somebody taking
over that post office at
gunpoint is not a thought.
But if you did that today you'd
be in federal prison in no time
and you could be charged with
treason.
Now, we can come back to that
issue of treason when the course
ends and revisit it,
if you want,
about this war.
But by and large every federal
installation in a seceded state,
the seven seceded states,
had been seized by those
states, Confederate states,
except Fort Sumter.
And Fort Sumter was a brand new
fort;
oh God, it can't be more than
200, maybe 300 yards across in
diameter.
It had just been built in the
late 1850s as part of the
coastal fort system.
Big, huge, high stone walls,
about 20 feet high.
It sits out at the mouth of
Charleston Harbor,
here.
It is nearly a mile from Fort
Sumter to the tip of the town of
Charleston, which is here;
from the Battery Park in
Charleston to the fort is nearly
a mile.
You can almost not see it.
There is today a monument--I
wish I had a slide of it to show
you.
It's one of my favorite,
for strange reasons,
Civil War monuments;
thousands upon thousands of
Civil War monuments.
Many of them are so generic you
don't even notice them.
This one you notice.
It's right at the tip of
Battery Park in Charleston,
where they used to hang
pirates.
It looks right out at Fort
Sumter.
It was put up in the early
twentieth century.
It's a Confederate monument of
a winged Roman soldier--I think
Roman because the helmet,
I'm told, is Roman.
He's some combination of a
winged creature and a soldier.
He's about four times the size
of life.
He is looking out at Fort
Sumter, and the inscription
around the bottom says,
"To the defenders of
Charleston," quote,
"Count them happy who for their
faith and courage endured a
great fight."
I'm going to repeat that:
"Count them happy who for their
faith and courage endured a
great fight."
On our monuments of this war,
almost all of them,
you will find almost nothing
about what caused the war or
even about what its consequences
were--almost all of them.
It was just a great fight,
and the dead are happy.
Well, what to do about Fort
Sumter?
In his First Inaugural of March
4,1861, Lincoln promised,
he said--promised to,
quote, "hold,
occupy and possess remaining
federal property."
Now think about it.
If Lincoln and the Republicans
are going to make a stand
against secession--and once he
finally comes into office--by
the way the day he entered
office all that federal property
had been taken by those seven
states,
it's already done;
he inherits this situation.
Now he could've backed away and
continued to try to
negotiate--and there was a
compromise negotiation under
John J.
Crittenden, a Kentucky Senator,
in Washington,
for awhile going on in late
February.
It never came up with anything
new.
They were going to try again a
geographic boundary out in the
West with slavery;
although don't forget the Dred
Scott decision had declared that
illegal.
They were going to try to rev
up something again about
fugitive slaves to satisfy the
South.
They just couldn't come up with
any new ideas.
And Lincoln could've tried to
continue the whole compromise
negotiation conventions,
he could have.
Or he could've held firm to the
Republican position that
secession was illegal and
impossible and unconstitutional,
and had to be stopped.
But if he lets Fort Sumter
go--there was a garrison there
led by a colonel named
Anderson--he just lets it go,
in effect he's saying,
"well, maybe all that seizure
of federal property is
legitimate,
maybe secession is possible,"
right?
It was about the only place he
could've taken a stand,
if he was going to take a
stand.
Well, Lincoln was buying time,
and he took a whole month of
time before he acted.
He was hoping for what he
called privately,
quote, "voluntary
reconstruction."
He was hoping for saner minds
in the South to--a Union spirit
in the South to somehow take
hold.
And there's much been said over
the years about Lincoln
over-estimating Union sentiment
across the South.
He may have indeed
over-estimated Union sentiment.
But there was a good deal of it.
There were a lot of frightened
people.
In the upstate counties of
Virginia and Western Virginia
and in western North Carolina
and eastern Tennessee and
northern Georgia,
those unionist pockets of the
South were scared about this,
because they have to make
terrible decisions now.
If this goes to war,
who do they go with?
Can't stay home.
Well, Major Robert Anderson had
about eighty men.
He was from Kentucky.
There's some slaveholding in
his background but he'll never
end up with the South.
Commissioners from South
Carolina had come to Washington
as early as January of 1861 to
negotiate that specific fort's
release;
they wanted it.
The federal government had
basically stonewalled it.
President Buchanan,
the lame duck president,
tried actually to re-enforce
the fort;
and by re-enforce the fort I
mean send food to the garrison
of troops.
Between January 5 and 9,
of 1861, Buchanan--the only act
Buchanan even tried to make
about secession,
he was just begging to get out
of office--Buchanan sent a ship
called the Star of the West,
full of supplies down the coast
of Fort Sumter to feed the men.
Shore batteries around the
harbor actually opened up fire,
and one had a direct hit on the
ship, but nothing came of it.
Note, it's January 5 to 9.
South Carolina was the only
seceded state.
It wasn't until the 11^(th)
that Mississippi went and then
Georgia and then about six
others, in the next three weeks.
Lincoln's April Policy,
if you like,
was a process of trying to buy
time, and if there was to be war
or firing or shooting about Fort
Sumter,
he was trying to make sure the
shots were fired by the South.
Now, there were hawks in his
administration,
there were hawks in the
Republican Party who wanted him
to act faster.
One of them wrote to Lincoln
privately and said,
quote, "Give up Sumter,
sir, and you are as dead
politically as John Brown is
physically."
Newspapers across the North,
strongly Republican newspapers,
started to print headlines
like: "Do We Have a
Government?;"
"Wanted, a Policy;"
or, "Come to the Point Mr.
Lincoln."
And so on.
People were ready now--do
something!
Now his Secretary of State,
duly appointed in great part,
as Doris Kearns Goodwin has
shown and argued in a recent
best-selling book,
Team of Rivals,
was William H.
Seward, Lincoln's principle
rival for the nomination of the
Republican Party.
Lincoln not only put a few of
his enemies in his own cabinet
to control them and use them
politically--in the end made an
absolute best friend out of
William Seward--but not yet.
Seward was a dove on this.
Seward wanted to negotiate.
He urged evacuation of the fort
and then he said leave the door
open to voluntary reconstruction
as it might take hold around the
South,
as southerners might see that
this new Lincoln administration
was willing to talk.
And that isn't all that Seward
did.
Seward launched a crazy plan to
declare war on Spain and France
to direct America's attention
outward to the world and
therefore cause national unity.
[Laughter]
Wag the Dog--did you see
the movie?
Let's just go to war with Spain
and France and all those crazy
southerners will realize,
"oh, the nation is at risk!"
Lincoln immediately rejected
this idea, although
unfortunately it got out there
and the foreign ministers of
Spain and France needed
explanations,
thank you very much.
[Laughter]
Seward also made private
promises as Secretary of State
to southerners that Sumter would
ultimately be evacuated;
just hang in there, just wait.
When Lincoln found that out he
said to Seward--in effect--shut
up.
Now, Lincoln tried in his
approach to Sumter to separate
reinforcement of these troops,
a military act,
from provisions,
a humanitarian act,
and he wanted to stress the
latter.
He notified finally southern
officials--he never referred to
them as Confederate governments,
he just notified South
Carolina, he said--that he was
going to send food and
provisions to hungry soldiers.
Now who could be against that?
He's going to feed some people.
He called it "a mission of
humanity, bringing food to
hungry men," quote/unquote.
But the Confederate leadership
took this as a direct challenge.
And Lincoln did indeed send a
ship down the coast about the
8^(th) or 9^(th)--no 6^(th) or
7^(th) of April,
1861, and the prolonged
suspense finally came to an end.
That one ship was provisioned
with food.
Now, the truth is there were
some arms and some weapons in
the hold as well.
In the end it isn't going to
matter a lot.
The Confederate Cabinet met
under Jefferson Davis on the
9^(th) of April and they made a
decision that if Lincoln tried
to sail that ship into
Charleston Harbor they would
fire on it.
On the 11^(th) of April Major
Anderson, in the fort,
was given a chance to surrender
by the authorities in
Charleston.
He refused, and at 4:30 in the
morning, in the dark of night,
April 12,1861,
about 100 cannon from all
around Charleston Harbor--100
federal cannons originally,
now seized by the Confederate
States of America--opened up and
bombarded Fort Sumter for
thirty-five hours.
Anderson's men hid underground,
in dugouts.
They'd been well prepared for
this.
And none of them died in the
bombardment of thousands of
shells lobbed into the fort.
The relief expedition arrived
out at the mouth of the harbor
during the firing,
and it never got to the fort.
On the 14^(th) of April,
after the bombardment ended,
Anderson was forced to
surrender the fort,
to take down the United States
flag.
A brand new Confederate States
flag with stars and bars was put
up.
And then Anderson's men held a
gun salute, 21-gun salute,
and the first casualties of the
war occurred when two of
Anderson's troops were killed on
a powder keg that blew up
because it was too close to one
of the muskets.
Four Aprils later--620,000 dead
and 1.2 million wounded--the
flag will go back up at Fort
Sumter on April 14,1862.
It'll be attended by William
Lloyd Garrison and 3000 freed
people.
But that's a long way away.
The day after the firing on
Fort Sumter all across the
country the headline was "War."
And Lincoln sent an Executive
Order, not declaring
war--Lincoln's position on this
was clear, to him anyway,
that no nation can declare war
on itself.
He'd never accepted secession
as legally constitutional or
appropriate.
But he called for 75,000
volunteers to,
quote, "put down a domestic
insurrection."
And in the Constitution,
the President of the United
States is given control over the
military to put down domestic
insurrection.
He called it a rebellion.
Now, the most important
immediate result of the firing
on Fort Sumter,
of course, was the secession of
the Upper South,
part of the Upper South.
Where's my map?
Oh I apologize,
I should've had that map right.
Well, you remember the map.
Four more southern states,
slave states,
will secede in the wake of
Sumter.
The most pivotal,
of course, was Virginia.
But note, Virginia had held a
secession convention back in
February and decisively voted
against secession.
After Fort Sumter,
in this state of war hysteria
and fever and fear,
and under now this new argument
that what the Lincoln
Administration had really done
was an act of coercion against
the South--coercion--now the
feeding of some 80 soldiers in a
fort was being interpreted as
coercion--okay.
But Virginia quickly,
overnight, held a new secession
convention--actually the State
Legislature held it--and it
voted eighty-eight to
fifty-five--note the vote--
eighty-eight to fifty-five;
lots of those "no" votes,
almost all of those "no" votes
coming from the western part of
Virginia--West Virginia didn't
exist yet--the western part of
Virginia where there was very
little slavery,
and some of the upper counties
of Virginia.
April 17^(th),
only three days after the
surrender of Fort Sumter,
Virginia seceded from the
Union.
By May 6^(th) Arkansas seceded
by a vote of sixty-nine to one,
in secession convention.
North Carolina,
on May 20^(th),
voted to--and look where North
Carolina is now,
it's between Virginia and South
Carolina;
what are they going to do?
They voted unanimously in
convention to secede.
And finally on June 8^(th),
by a two to one vote of a
popular referendum--these were
done in different ways in
different states--in a popular
referendum Tennessee,
in a two to one vote,
approximately,
seceded from the Union.
The Confederacy was now eleven
states.
It would never really be any
more than that.
But there was great tension
about what Maryland,
Delaware, Kentucky and Missouri
would actually do.
Lincoln is reported to have
said that he hoped to have God
on his side, but he was certain
he wanted Kentucky.
Now, there's been a whole
flurry of emails recently on the
Slavery and History Network of
historians online trying to
trace that quote,
just in the past couple of
weeks.
And the truth is nobody can
actually find it anywhere.
It's one of those many,
many, many, probably apocryphal
Lincoln quotes.
He probably said something like
it, somewhere,
but I just couldn't resist
using it;
I've used it for so many years.
So footnote,
might be apocryphal--okay?
He did need Kentucky,
whatever he said.
All of those states were deeply
divided about what to do,
and what they will do,
and the war will prove that,
and they will be terrible,
horrible places to be,
geographically,
emotionally,
physically in the war.
Maryland was horribly divided.
Note where it is,
it's right above Washington,
D.C.
Approximately 50,000 white men
fought for the Union,
in Maryland,
in the Civil War.
Approximately--I'm sorry,
about 50,000 white men in
Maryland fought in the Civil
War;
30,000 on the Union side,
20,000 on the Confederate side;
and of those 30,000 on the
Union side, 9000 of them were
African-Americans.
Kentucky had about 50,000 men
fight for the Union and about
35,000 men fight for the
Confederacy,
and per capita Kentucky
produced more African-American
soldiers for the Union Army than
any other state,
24,000 total.
Missouri, the numbers are even
greater.
In Missouri,
about 80,000 men fought for the
Union, about 30,000 fought for
the Confederacy,
and there were about 3,000 that
weren't on either side,
they were guerillas looking for
the best payday--early versions
of Jesse James,
without ideology.
Later Jesse James got real
ideology though;
that's another story.
And folks, especially in those
states, this was
immediately--you've heard all
the clichés about how it
was a fratricidal conflict and a
brothers' war--immediately it
was a brothers' war,
and thousands of families,
in April and May and June of
1861, brothers and fathers
looked each other in the eye and
had to decide what they would
do.
Henry Clay had seven grandsons
in Kentucky--three fought for
the Union and four fought for
the Confederacy.
John J.
Crittenden of Kentucky--he's
the senator of the Crittenden
Compromise efforts,
in the secession winter--had
one son who became a general in
the Union Army and one son who
became a general in the
Confederate Army.
Both survived,
and I've always wanted to know
about Crittenden family
reunions;
but I've never looked into it.
Mrs.
Lincoln, Mary Todd Lincoln,
who was of course born and
raised in Kentucky,
had four brothers who all
fought for the Confederacy,
and three brothers-in-law who
fought for the Confederacy.
It will lead later to all kinds
of charges of--well some charges
about treason against her and so
on, sympathies for the South and
so on and so on.
John C.
Pemberton from Pennsylvania
became a Confederate general and
was ultimately the general who
surrendered Vicksburg to Grant
in 1863.
George Thomas was Virginia
born, old slaveholding family,
but he never resigned his
commission and he became known
as the Rock of Chickamauga;
the Union general who won the
Battle of Chickamauga was a
Virginian.
And these stories go on and on
and on.
There's the story of Clifton
and William Prentice.
One of them fought in the
6^(th) Maryland Infantry,
a Union regiment.
The other fought in the 2^(nd)
Maryland Infantry,
a Confederate regiment.
Both were wounded at Petersburg
on April 2, on the same day,
1865, in the last week of the
war,
and they died in cots right
next to each other in a field
hospital.
And the list goes on and on.
Now, when people went to war in
1861, what did they say they
were doing?
What did they say were their
aims?
What were their reasons?
We have thousands of diary
entries and letters and
editorials and all sorts of
things to draw upon.
But on the northern side what
you find that summer is not only
this sense that this will be a
short war--and that's a preface
worth pointing out--but people
would say over and over they
were fighting for the flag,
they were fighting for the
Union, they were fighting for
the Constitution,
they were fighting to save the
Republic,
they were fighting to,
quote, "save the government."
And you keep hearing those
phrases and you keep thinking,
"oh man, these are
abstractions,
what were they really doing?"
You keep reading and you keep
hearing them say the same damn
thing.
Well, there's a lot of good
scholarship on this now that
shows us that in 1860s America
the U.S.
Constitution was important to
people.
They saw it as a kind of
protection;
they saw it as a source of
social order.
They saw the American nation as
now something they were directly
experiencing;
millions were directly
experiencing the government as
never before in those debates of
the 1850s.
And as I've said before now,
voter turnout just zoomed in
the 1850s, to seventy-five and
eighty percent,
in each general election from
1852 on.
Phillip Paludan,
in a marvelous book about this,
has said that the Constitution
and the government,
for so many northerners,
was like a shield of
protection, and that southern
secession now was not just a
threat to this government,
it was a threat to social order
itself, and it therefore had to
be stopped.
A New Hampshire farmer who
became a buck private in 1861
said, quote, "The question now
is country or no country,
liberty or slavery?"
There's a beautiful clarity to
that isn't there?
Now I don't know what he said,
after Bull Run or after
Antietam, or after Spotsylvania,
if he survived.
A fifty year-old railroad
contractor named Robert
McAllister threw down his
lucrative job in 1861 and
enlisted,
at age fifty,
quote, "to help us put down
this wicked and unjustifiable
rebellion.
Our country and property is
worth nothing if we don't,
nor will life be secure."
This is all over people's
letters.
They said they were fighting
for liberty;
of course, so did southerners.
Now, another argument here,
and again Phil Paludan has made
this better than anyone I think,
is he's argued that southerners
and northerners have sort of
come to view the U.S.
Constitution,
this document we live under,
in different ways;
that northerners had come to
see the Constitution as a kind
of protector,
much violated now by
Kansas-Nebraska Act,
Dred Scott decision,
et cetera, whereas southerners
had come to see that
constitution more as a
destroyer,
as something to fear,
that might, if the wrong people
get hold of it,
begin to attack or erode their
society.
There were a lot of people,
particularly in the North but
then quickly in the South as
well,
who when this war broke out
began to see it in terms of
cosmic dualism,
good and evil--God was entering
history.
Right away, Christian America
began to interpret this in
millennial terms.
God had a quarrel with America,
people started arguing;
and they're going to really be
arguing this after the enormous
bloodshed of '62 and '63 when
they have to try to explain why
this is happening.
They're going to say God has an
appointment with America and
he's going to decide whose sins
are worse.
Now, on the southern side,
as I said, people have to make
tough choices,
horrible choices.
Who do they go with?
They join their neighbors or
oppose their neighbors?
Mary Chesnut,
the great diarist from South
Carolina who indeed kept the
most famous diary by a southern
woman--there are many of them.
She remembered March and April
1861 this way--and here we have
another kind of beautiful
clarity.
"We separated," said Mary
Chesnut, "because of
incompatibility of temper.
We are divorced,
North from South,
because we hate each other so
much."
Okay Mary, I get it--divorce
papers--you hate us.
Walter Nugent,
a Mississippi lawyer,
who did not own slaves,
nevertheless declared in 1861
that without slave labor--now
the slaveholder is arguing
this--that without slave labor
the country would be,
quote, in his words,
"a barren waste and desolate
plane.
We can only live and exist by
this species of labor and hence
I am willing to continue the
fight to the last."
Well, Nugent hadn't seen any
fight yet, but never mind.
Well, in the end the South,
from the highest ranks of
Jefferson Davis on down to buck
privates,
are all going to say they were
fighting for their liberty;
everybody was fighting for
their liberty.
And when blacks get into this
thing in '62 and '63,
they're fighting for their
liberty too.
"Everybody," as Lincoln later
said, "everybody declared for
liberty."
Now make no mistake,
I love to quote my friend Uriah
over there on the stone wall in
Woolsey,
and I walk--every time--every
morning on the way over here to
class I go by and I rub my
finger on his name for,
I don't know,
good luck or something;
if I teach here long enough
it's probably going to wear off.
But everybody in the Union Army
wasn't a Uriah Parmelee;
in fact, the vast majority were
not going to free the slaves
just yet.
There's a story of a Yankee
soldier in Virginia in 1861 who
encounters a slave woman and
he's taken that woman's goods
and that woman says,
"Well wait a minute,
aren't you coming here to help
us?"
And he answered her and said--.
No, the woman says,
"We were told you were coming
here to help us and instead you
steal from us."
And the soldier replied,
"You're a god-damn liar.
I'm fighting for $14.00 a month
and the Union."
Well there's a beautiful
clarity in that too--I ain't
here to free you.
Oh, I got behind on this
outline, didn't I?
That's okay,
that's actually just fine.
When we resume--don't leave
yet--when we resume next Tuesday
I will talk a little bit about
West Point and what happened at
West Point when Union and
Confederate,
or southern and northern men
begin to leave.
And then we'll begin the war.
We'll talk about comparative
strengths and so on.
But let me leave you for today
and the weekend,
if you don't mind,
with Walt Whitman again.
Whitman's opening poem of his
immortal collection called
Drum Taps,
in a kind of agonizing way may
have captured what was in the
heads of most Americans in 1861.
"To the drum-taps prompt," he
writes, "the young men falling
in and arming;
the mechanics arming,
(the trowel,
the jack-plane,
the blacksmith's hammer,
tost aside with
precipitation;).
The blood of the city is
up--arm'd, arm'd!,
the cry everywhere;
The flags flung out from the
steeples of churches,
and from all the public
buildings and stores;
The tearful parting--the mother
kisses her son--the son kisses
the mother;
(Loth is the mother to
part--yet not a word does she
speak to detain him;).
War, an armed race is advancing;
the welcome for battle.
No turning away now.
War, be it weeks,
months or years,
an armed race is advancing and
it welcomes it."